the
weekend that we just had
trying to figure out the right words
it's not funny anymore guys if it ever
was and it was never funny to many of us
if it ever was
this trump cult
is not funny anymore they are motivated
tens of millions of them still want
trump again
they are willing to travel
they are willing to pay just to hear
from the guy
he is increasingly
the dangerous cult leader
they are increasingly the dangerous
cultists i just finished reading jeff
gwyn's great book about charles manson
and when i read about the followers of
manson and what they were willing to do
in their case they were willing to kill
it's hard not to think about trump
cultists and the danger of this group of
people
cannot be overstated there was a rally
in michigan over the weekend we're going
to look at what trump said we're going
to look at what the speaker said we're
going to look at what the attendees said
and one of the things that is concerning
is
the trumpists who now come across my
streams of these events
they are angrier than ever they used to
ignore my coverage of these rallies
before now dozens and dozens of them
will email me furious maybe it's because
they are angry that he lost and he's no
longer president maybe it's because they
are emboldened maybe it's because they
don't like that trump is making no sense
whatsoever at these rallies but
for whatever reason they are very very
triggered by our coverage of these
rallies let's start with the things that
donald trump said yesterday it was a
very glitchy night there were like five
or six of those weird glitch twitch
issues
i'm not going to play all of them here's
one where i guess he was trying to talk
about zuckerberg drop boxes and he just
glitched and it was very strange the
elimination of zuckerberg dropbox i call
them the
unlock boxes and it's always that
shoulder glitch right when he makes a
mistake it's not clear what it is we
don't know is it neurological is it
psychological we don't know there were
half a dozen of them yesterday i won't
bore you with more of them we're used to
it up at this uh up until this point in
time
i made a good faith effort to find
anything that trump said that was true
and here's the best i came up with trump
said at one point during the rally
in russia there is such a rigged press
that some russians don't even really
understand
the nature of the war that is going on
that was true
everything else he said was false you
know
they say that in russia
the people in russia don't even know
they're having a war
because they have a rigged press we have
the same rig press maybe not quite as
severe but it'll be there in the not too
distant future now of course that last
part isn't true although trump would
love to have a rigged press that only uh
uh praises him but that is not true
as crazy as this is going to sound
donald trump floated the idea of going
back to afghanistan
he said what we might go back and the
crowd cheered guys i can't do it i can't
do it it was years of saying he would
get us out and he failed to do it
and then biden got us out and now trump
is so upset with how biden got us out
that he says maybe we'll go back and get
our stuff
and the crowd cheers understand we're
talking about in order to do that you've
got to send troops back in and the crowd
cheers it it's it's beyond belief you
have many citizens
that the taliban is holding they didn't
get enough with the 85 billion dollars
maybe you ought to go in and take it
back
dumbest thing i've ever seen go back in
finest military equipment in the world
they have them from the goggles to the
seven hundred thousand machine guns
it it is it is incredible
i'm not aware of trump ever having
mentioned joe biden's white house press
secretary jenn saki before
but he did at the saturday rally
and he referred to her
as the woman with the really beautiful
red hair just every there can he can't
talk about anything in a normal way here
is trump on gensake
and then
the woman with this really beautiful red
hair
she left
and she was hit so hard by the military
because they knew i was right the
military understood i was right you know
she's going to msdnc you know that bro
right
it does appear that it does appear that
jenn saki is going to be when she leaves
going to msnbc that act so i guess trump
told two truths in his nearly two hour
speech
they need a redhead they don't have a
redhead over there so they need a red
hat
very slurry as you can imagine and the
crowd just absolutely loving all of it
here is another lie that trump continues
to tell trump once again claiming that
he was the recipient of an award that
does not exist they get worse
and then i was named a long time ago i
was named did you know this a long time
i don't know your chamber of commerce
somebody who the hell knows what it is
they named me the man of the year in
michigan
and i got up
and i said they're stealing your car
business
and i was really rebuked they said that
wasn't a very nice thing to say i said
but now two things one
i don't know why trump was so sweaty
throughout the entire event many of our
viewers were asking that on saturday
night but that award doesn't exist the
crowd cheers anyway it doesn't matter
whether you know if you go this this is
the sick reality guys this trump's been
claiming he got this award man of
michigan man of the year for for a very
long time
there's no evidence that it exists so
it's been researched by multiple media
outlets they tried since 2016 media
outlets have been trying to verify that
trump got this award there's no evidence
he got it there's no evidence the award
exists
if you go to a trumpist and say you know
that award doesn't exist
he'll that they would come up with
something like
well he should have gotten that award
that award should exist it should be
created it should be given to donald
trump this is how delusional these
cultists are
now at another point in the rally
trump made a completely unintelligible
rant
about
we figured out later he's talking about
jeff fortenbury fortenberry who was
convicted of lying to the fbi and
concealing information criminal okay and
trump seemed to sort of be making light
of what happened to jeff fortenberry but
it like didn't make any sense listen to
this million dollars you know
in a great state nebraska
a congressman
is being put in jail over a few dollars
that he possibly didn't even know
anything about he's going to jail a few
thousand dollars
and yet
this guy gives
417 million dollars to all these states
the money it's passed around like uh
like pizza like pizza at a party
and nothing happens to him they're
putting this congressman i don't know
him well but he's a congressman and it
was over a very small amount of money
they're gonna put him in jail
over a number of thousands like twenty
thousand dollars
that's the it first was like no money
and then it was thousands and then then
it's 20 thousands jeff fortenberry was
convicted of lying to the fbi like many
trump associates have done concealing
information in an investigation about
illegal contributions made by a foreign
national to his re-election campaign
does that ring a bell to anybody sounds
very similar to some of the
investigations into the people around
trump trump then had a sort of dog
whistle attack
on primarily but not exclusively black
athletes who have knelt during the
national or is it knelt or kneeled
during the national anthem saying you
only kneel
um uh
you don't kneel or wait listen and
americans kneel to god and god alone
okay there we go
okay so you guys get the implication you
don't kneel during the anthem you only
kneel to god
my senses trump's never been on his
knees for jesus in his life that's my
sense of the guy and then lastly trump
starts to do sort of like a
impression of how he would do a
concession speech
but then he stops for fear that the
media will edit it in an unfair way be a
lot easier for me to do like many people
have done get up and just say
congratulations uh
whoever it is i'm running against i mean
if you're running i'd say
congratulations joe
now watch if i say it i don't want to
say it because they'll put it on like
this is what they do whoa remember the
russia if you're listening thing so they
cut it off immediately because it was a
joke russia if you're listening to do
this or that with her emails or whatever
the hell it was
they admit and then i laughed they left
the whole place was left but they cut it
off immediately said russia if you're
listening god nobody cut it off there
that is a lie nobody cut it off there so
this is the dangerous cultist he has
followers he has influence they're not
going away
let's now look at some of the other
people who spoke at the rally
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video